but i'm wondering like if this smile is
is it more smiley than the mona lisa
or less smiley
like who's smiling more probably mona
lisa
yeah a little bit we have one more game
which i think i've i've already kind of
determined this game is going to be my
top pick
so this is yeah arguably one of the best
games played out of the whole tournament
and we'll see why oh i have a picture
maybe after the game i'll show my
picture of the sheriff
i played sure of back in 2017
in lafayette he absolutely crushed me
it's on youtube and people can search
for it but this game
he was black he plays
so he plays a slav but i would like to
call this
a reverse in london so already i'm i'm
excited about this
night h4 played yeah the thing is like
when you're playing reverse london white
has an extra tempo to
do different types of things so this is
a very typical move
black has to concede the bishop hair
eventually
pretty sure this is mostly theory yeah
still theory
uh so what gets the bishop here black
gets a nice kind of open h-file
shiraz being sneaky hitting the h-pawn
um like castles now it's not actually so
sneaky because if you take the h-pawn
you lose b7 that would be sad
so instead knight d7 played
maybe pretty soon there could be threats
of taking
so white takes on d5 first take back
with the c
pawn unleashing the c file pinning the
knight
king b1 and following the ben feingold
rule
should know this uh playing white is a
pretty strong player
grand master 2550 likes to have extra
y's in the name
[Music]
um i i'll admit i haven't heard of this
player
veneri de nil but um
okay king b1 a6
so black's still like pretty flexible
black could decide to castle
whichever way um but a6 is an indicator
b5 is coming there could be some queen
side attack
okay queen b getting off the c file
so h4 and now b5
so yeah b5 very natural move
controlling c4 idea to probably bring
the knight to c4
um so white plays a4 i was looking at
this earlier
and i was trying to like figure out the
next move from black in this position
and it looks very inviting to play b4
um which shirov did not play
and before it does attack the knight the
problem is it just closes down the queen
sign
i'm sure like either knight a2 or knight
e2
and like but i can never open the b file
so i really like what shirov did here
he just castles he leaves the tension
between the pawns
knowing that he'll be happy if light
tries to grab the free pawn
because the open file is more valuable
and yeah if bishop takes or queen takes
there's queen a7
if knight takes there's still going to
be more pressure and
there'd probably be full compensation
for the pawn here
so um yeah after castling it turns into
a sharper position
like white obviously wants to attack on
the king's side and black wants to
attack on the queen side
so white play the logical move a5
which does a couple of things attempts
to keep the b-file closed
also prevents the knight from coming to
c4 via b6
a5 maybe looks weak at first but is
usually defended by the bishop
so the game continues
rook c8 very natural square for the rook
only open file in the position white
plays bishop d3
okay completing development and if i'm
not mistaken i think
as at this moment shiroff plays a really
surprising move
but made it work really beautifully yeah
maybe
maybe some people in the chat have seen
this game so i'll go ahead and show the
move
because it looks like black should
really be focusing on the queen side
like maybe
double up the rooks um maybe considered
b4
but the move plane is queen g3
which looks so counter-intuitive like
you
really don't have any business putting
the queen on a square where it can
easily be attacked
where it looks like it's going to be
used as fuel for white's
eventual expansion but it does slow down
the g pawn advance so in some way it's
prophylactic
and there's a simple idea of just taking
the pawn and then getting initiative
where if white allows queen digs g2 then
white's position can crumble
um so white did the logical thing plays
rook rook cg1
and then i think we're gonna see another
another really cool move is coming up i
think it's in this position yeah rook c4
so two pretty unexpected moves in a row
at first glance it just looks like a
free exchange
however black is dreaming of opening the
b
file and if white
dares to take on c4
black not only wins connect four but
opens the b file
and i think this is this is probably
just a a crushing attack with rook b8s
combination
of this um white has no attack on the
king's side the queen can infiltrate via
f2 um i'll say i haven't checked this
with the engine but
it looks really really difficult for
white so white didn't take on c4
uh white just kind of left left the rook
sitting here
plays f4 so rook c8
i'm just building up pressure queen d1
and now b4 so getting the b pawn rolling
has the rooks doubled on the only open
file yeah again if white
if white ever takes here white can't
really take the rook right right away
because takes
and you don't want the pawn coming here
because of traffic
oh happy birthday welcome hope this can
get you some tasty teas
i'll put it towards the t fund thanks so
much regretful something something
um yeah if you're just joining you're
catching the final game analysis of this
stream
okay so knight's attacked has to move 92
in some way it looks like 92 helped
white and now it looks like the queen is
getting stuck here
there's another idea of f4 the queen
can't go back home
it's stuck in white's home but shira's
not afraid queen g4
so again the rook's attack but you don't
really want to mess with the
potential queenside pawns so knight
knight c1 bagging to trade queens
and this position it looks like black
has no choice like
where does the queen go it could move
back to g3 however
there is there's a really beautiful idea
in the position
which essentially avoids a queen trade
bam knight e4 leaving the queen hanging
this is a prime moment to say oh no my
queen
i don't think shira was was streaming
definitely
wasn't streaming probably didn't say oh
no my queen
but that's so beautiful
if white takes the queen the idea of
course
we win the bishop with check and now
we're gonna see
we're gonna see an anastasia's mate
imagine king a2
b3 and the rook is entering
a4 it's just mate the same idea
if king a1 again i assume b3
opening up the row oh thank you g space
um yeah so box down the whole queen i
guess won back the bishop
but there's no stopping mate these
pieces
are not really invited to the party on
the queen side
uh maybe knight a2 delays and mates
oh actually i didn't analyze this line
knight a2
because if if this move then this move
ooh so how does wait a minute
how does black win here i assume there's
a win
where's the win chat help me
let's go back to this position as is b3
the right move here
oh it's only minus 0.4 or what so what
could have gone into this line
oh and now it's minus 11. oh that's so
funny
so it took stockfish about what like
four seconds there
to find the move it said like only
slightly better for black and then it
said completely winning
so i assume we're missing some long-term
idea which might be too difficult for
the twitch chat maybe even too difficult
for me
i mean we can just like c minus 11.
so i assume that there might be some
long-term forced mate
okay let's let's see let's see so b3 oh
maiden 12
b3 it's so funny you play the move and
then stockfish just forgets
like it just said made in 12 now it says
draw
this is why the engine can't be trusted
at low depth
okay now it says maiden 11.
wait let's try and um can i press
spacebar
okay so i can press spacebar to play the
engine moves
but hide the
yeah i'm hiding all the analysis so
actually i saw the move as v takes a2
but i don't know if i fully understand
it so it takes
we were looking at this but maybe didn't
look deep enough
takes
i'm sure shearer i've calculated like
all of this so where's a win
rook c4 here maybe
or do we take another c4
the problem is there's b oh there's b oh
okay
so i think i think we're on to something
i i think
some people in chat have some idea of
taking
takes and then wow so rooksy for
threatening mate
there's b3 only move there's also b4
though
maybe we should play rook c4 first
rook c4 then if b4 we have this move
which is winning
so rook c4 forcing b3 then we take takes
here king here and then bishop here
threatening mate and
white can't stop bishop c3 let's see it
rook c4
what knight c5 and no one in chat said
knight c5 but does this work
oh there's queen d1 oh
does rook c5 only of knight c5 or knight
b3 work
open knight b3 we just repeat and then
play knight c5
knight c5 so we sacked a queen
now we're sacking we're just like
letting the pawn take our knight
but look at it
i'm still not fully understanding this
oh
maybe now i understand it oh
so we played knight c5 threatening mate
with idea at first i was thinking
like we want to use this diagonal but we
just want to take
and we're threatening the anastasia is
made again
like we saw this idea earlier in like a
different game
and in this case if the b pawn moves
this is just me this is instamate we
don't even need our rooks
or any of our pawns knight and bishop do
all the work
that's so nice and white has
well i can't do anything with these
pieces so it's easy to like play through
the the game and not be aware of the
sign
that would've been so nice if if this
actually played out
what happened in the game was also nice
um so just like a slow motion replay
like how we got to that line
so this all started with knight e4
so of course it takes like very precise
calculation
so the line was takes here king
here and then b3
bishop b1 that engine's just hopping up
and down because it's confused
there was knight a2 takes
takes and only winning ideas knight c5
here
we didn't even look at queen a1 or queen
d1 i should say
but here okay we're winning back the
queen maybe it's still not simple
oh it's still meat though how's this
made knight cb3
at this point we're up a piece
oh we're still lifting the rook oh
that's so nice
so we we're just we don't even have to
convert an end game
because again we're threatening the
anastasia's mate moving the b
pawn is the only resource uh
like b3 but then we play this we're
stacking a rook
but then bishop here there's no defense
to this move
rook b1 delays it that's so nice
all the pieces would play a role in this
mate you need the rook to defend the
bishop you need the knight to
control b1
okay so
apparently white saw all of that because
he didn't take the queen
he played bishop e2 praying for
repetition
shirov saves the queen aligns
with the king threatening nasty
discoveries white moves back
it's still not over knight f6 played
and now
so basically like trapping the queen
winning material
but black has basically the same idea
as we just saw black can just take
what happened the game after takes the
queen just returns
to g4 so the same idea as earlier
and i i don't think white had a great
way of like
surviving here because idea was just
knight g4 and
it's such domination and the bishop is
stuck
kind of defending along this diagonal
so did white resign here oh no
so white white to take the queen yeah
this is good etiquette
like when someone plays this brilliantly
it's like sack the queen
the second queen sacrificed this game
now white takes it
and see how it uh it finishes off
knight takes d2
and okay in this case it's a bit
different because the queen left the
first rank
and the rook also left the first rank so
here black's just winning
the knight on c1 and then b3 will be
will be mating
after this this king a2 inmates
and again all these pieces play a role
[Music]
so really cool game
yeah i think out of all the game like
out of the games that we've looked at
this almost certainly deserves to be
the top pick i think i'm supposed to
tweet
i'm supposed to tweet my top picks so
anyway i hope people enjoyed this game i
hope it was worth waiting around for the
people that did
wait around i'll probably post this game
analysis
on youtube and i'll link i'll link this
whole study so if people want to see
more really cool games from the olympiad
uh check out the link in the video
description
um i don't do this too often where like
i'll analyze
top level like current games i know agud
mata does this all the time
but it is nice to see some some
brilliance
in in high level play hey it's admiral
welcome back sorry i am
late eric oh no worries i'll catch you
was watching your title stream and you
mentioned you needed to unlock the
emote slot what do you need to do that
ah i think we did like after that stream
we had to hit a certain number of
subscribers
and uh we we hit like 15 or 1600
so i have a few more emotes to add so
people watching in the future
on youtube if you want access to emotes
you can come over to twitch follow to
get notified when i go live
and subscribe to get access to all the
emotes
and i'll see you in the future
so the game that we played is actually
on youtube
i think he got a winning position in
like 13 moves
it was really cool it was like a small
local tournament that shira just showed
up
and swashnikov too
actually after the tournament it was
just like a rapid
like morning to early afternoon
um he drove me
like he sure i've drove me and a friend
to
like have dinner with a few other like
local grand masters
yeah here was uh so i was on board one i
think after five rounds
oh no after six so for around six i i
was tied for first
with svashnikov so it was a brief moment
i was uh
ahead of shirov but then svashnikov beat
me and so did shirov
i beat i think i beat mises
like a notable gm actually so i played
rousseau's in the last round
and we drew i had a sneaky stalemate
trap against roses
oh it's so great they don't really do
this in the u.s
but like in europe they have an award
ceremony
where the winner just gives a speech it
was all in russian
maybe that's the main language in latvia
and i don't really speak russian
but it was cool yeah so here's me
playing uh spashnikov
this picture is more in focus he beat me
too
i play the london but he neutralized and
then he just
completely outplayed me so there's a
youtube channel it's called rapid chess
so if you google if you type into
youtube
like my name and sveshikov or my name in
shiraz
you can see the actual gameplay
um yeah unfortunately like you can't
it's just hands moving
but i i was white and he was black and
eventually like he beat me